real quick I got a surprise this is a
very fun surprise for me
I am going to do a hangout Hawk only
garyvee mystery box right now
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been fantastic it's nice to see you
brother let's discuss your health and
wellness habits because I know that is
something that you're big on yes and a
lot of entrepreneurs and business owners
is this is something that they're
severely lacking yes and I was the far
majority of my career yeah
[Music]
I think a lot about being 90 to 100 I
think about who am I going to be at that
point how much wisdom can I like I
always think about like garyvee today is
trying to put out good into the world
and has a big platform well me a 90 to
100 I can be on some Yoda [ __ ] and if I
can hang for another 10 more years I can
leave more positive deposits and if I
have to do [ __ ] Bulgarian split
squats to be there then [ __ ] it I'm
gonna do it I really think that's like
literally exactly how my brain thinks
about it absolutely anything you can
control if you can make it better why
wouldn't you consider it and for me
working out is the hardest thing to this
day almost a decade later I do not want
to do it it does not come natural to me
it's you know I have such Envy for
people I'm making assumption just
because you're in such great shape I
always feel like for those people it's
kind of like business for me like
business for me comes natural
everything's easy
I'll always be great at it because I've
always been and I always will be but
like
you know I have a lot of envy and I
don't have a lot of Envy in my heart but
I have Envy for people that like
literally like love it can't wait to go
like for me that's not my reality but
it's so damn important I fight for it
thank you brother thank you sir
pleasure appreciate it
[Music]
so I actually thought about for the
first time a new book idea called hire
your best friends and family the first
five employees is everything hire your
best friends and family I have a very
different point of view like that's such
a common thing right like don't hire
friends and family I think it's the
complete reverse
I think it's higher friends and family
and then try to turn everybody else into
friends and family right like like
everybody in my life makes fun of me
that I only have my only friends are
like my employees like I can't help it
like I don't know like it is what it is
so
um I think um it'd be very human with
them be vulnerable be transparent be
candorous try to teach too many people
have too much of their self-esteem
wrapped up in them being the best at
their thing when they hire employees it
completely [ __ ] them up the biggest
reason people don't grow teams is
because of ego you're coming up with the
reasons of no versus the reasons of yes
and so like my answer is get the admin
to go full time hire the sales person
immediately and start learning through
the process of it
like maybe the first person won't be
right but you can't worry about who
you're going to hire before you hire
them
meaning like
you know what's going to happen you're
gonna You're Gonna Lose the client okay
but if you don't grow you won't grow
thank you you're welcome thanks quick I
got a surprise this is a very fun
surprise for me
I am going to do a hangout Hawk only
garyvee mystery box right now right now
in here there's already a bunch of stuff
in here for the team let me I want to do
some hardcore stuff yes give me this
give us a little hoodie but I'm gonna do
I'm gonna drop a big one right now I am
actually going to take
one of the ceramics
all right driven Dragon ceramic I'm
going to wrap that in here all right
what else okay this is very rare for me
but I'm giving up one of my hillbilly
gems hillbilly gym in the house
[Music]
I gotta get to my next meeting here's
how we're gonna do it the person that's
gonna win this box is the first person
with the number five in the chat right
now go
oh [ __ ] that was fast
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here that was
really well done I'm really impressed
[ __ ] [ __ ] gotta give it to him Jesus
Christ that [ __ ] [ __ ] the nice thing
is Chef's gonna give it away all right
love you Hawks call cough love you talk
soon see ya
[Music]
foreign
[Music]